foreign
[Music]
the Black Death the 1918 flu pandemic
covid-19
we tend to think of these catastrophic
world-changing pandemics as very
unlikely events
but between 1980 and 2020 at least three
diseases emerged that caused Global
pandemics covid-19 yes but also the 2009
swine flu and HIV AIDS disease outbreaks
are surprisingly common over the past
four centuries the longest stretch of
time without a documented outbreak that
killed at least 10 000 people was just
four years as bad as these smaller
outbreaks are they're far less deadly
than a covid-19 level pandemic in fact
many people born after the 1918 flu
lived their entire lives without
experiencing a similar world-changing
pandemic what's the probability that you
do too
there are several ways to answer this
question you could look at history a
team of scientists and Engineers who
took this approach cataloged all
documented epidemics and pandemics
between 1600 and 1950. they used that
data to do two things first to graph the
likelihood that an outbreak of any size
pops up somewhere in the world over a
set period of time
and second to estimate the likelihood
that that outbreak would get large
enough to kill a certain percentage of
the world's population
this graph shows that while huge
pandemics are unlikely they're not that
unlikely
the team used these two distributions to
estimate that the risk of a covid-19
level pandemic is about 0.5 percent per
year and could be as high as 1.4 percent
if new diseases emerge more frequently
in the future
and we'll come back to those numbers but
first let's look at another way to
estimate the likelihood of a future
pandemic modeling one from the ground up
for most pandemics to happen a pathogen
which is a microbe that can cause
disease has to spill over from its
normal host by making contact with and
infecting a human then the pathogen has
to spread widely Crossing International
boundaries and infecting lots of people
many variables determine whether a given
spillover event becomes a pandemic
for example the type of pathogen how
often humans come into close contact
with its animal Reservoir existing
immunity and so on
viruses are prime candidates to cause
the next big pandemic scientists
estimate that there are about 1.7
million as yet undiscovered viruses that
currently infect mammals and birds and
that roughly 40 percent of these have
the potential to spill over and infect
humans
a team of scientists built a model using
this information as well as data about
the global population air travel
networks how people move around in
communities country preparedness levels
and how people might respond to
pandemics
the model generated hundreds of
thousands of virtual pandemics the
scientists then used this catalog to
estimate that the probability of another
covid-19 level pandemic is 2.5 to 3.3
percent per year
to get a sense of how these risks play
out over a lifetime let's pick a value
roughly in the middle of all these
estimates two percent now let's build
what's called a probability tree diagram
to model all possible scenarios
first branch of the tree represents the
first year there's a two percent
probability of experiencing a covid-19
level pandemic which means there's a 98
probability of not experiencing one
second Branch same thing Third Branch
same and so on 72 more times there is
only one path that results in a fully
pandemic free lifetime 98 or 0.98
multiplied by itself 75 times which
comes out to roughly 22 percent
so the likelihood of living through at
least one more covid-19 level pandemic
in the next 75 years is 100 minus 22
percent or 78
78 percent
if we use the most optimistic yearly
estimate point five percent the lifetime
probability drops to 31 if we use the
most pessimistic one it jumps to 92
percent
31 is too high to ignore even if we get
lucky future Generations might not also
pandemics are usually random independent
events so even if the yearly probability
of a coveted 19 level pandemic is one
percent we could absolutely get another
one in 10 years
the good news is we now have tools that
make pandemics less destructive
scientists estimated that early Warning
Systems contact tracing social
distancing and other public health
measures saved over a million lives in
just the first six months of the
covid-19 pandemic in the U.S
not to mention the millions of lives
saved by vaccines
one day another pandemic will sweep the
globe but we can work to make that day
less likely to be tomorrow we can reduce
the risk of spillover events and we can
contain spillovers that do happen so
they don't become full-blown pandemics
imagine how the future might look if we
interacted with the animal world more
carefully and if we had well-funded open
access Global disease monitoring
programs ai-powered contact tracing and
isolation measures Universal vaccines
Next Generation antiviral drugs and
other Tech we haven't even thought of
it's in our power to change these
probabilities so we have a choice we
could do nothing and hope we get lucky
or we could take the threat seriously
enough that it becomes a self-defeating
prophecy
which Future Would you rather live in
luckily for us the viruses that cause
pandemics can and do go extinct find out
what it takes to make that happen and
how long with this video or watch this
video to learn more about the one
sickness we can never seem to get rid of
the common cold
[Music]